en 1922 la fierté d'un homme son secteur
mais également son fils ma femme voulait
que nous abandonnions tout ça on
pourrait déménager
c'est idiot qui vivent en ville et en
divorce
nous savons tous les deux que c'est ce
que tu veux la vie tu sais est rarement
juste et en particulier ici je crois
qu'il ya un autre homme en chaque homme
un homme sournois et je veux lavastre
nous toi ma fille ce qui viendra avec
moi ou ma messi chine en 1922
j'ai assassiné ma femme vous voulez un
verre de limonade chérif puis je
regardais à l'intérieur elle n'en
portait qu'une seule valise
il faudrait qu'une femme soit folle pour
quitter une jolie maison comme ça
[Musique]
je dirais non
tu nous as monter tous les deux
j'espère que dieu n'existe pas parce que
s'il n'ya pas thiais
enfin
il n'y a pas d' enfer
[Musique]
à